hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreign again we have a
little bit of interesting news to talk
about like a state of balance and a lot
of other things that came with that
so it was always like the view if you do
enjoy a subscribe before new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch shows and the leaks so
if want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out an update
that we stay subscribe to the channel by
Twitter and discord will be in the
description down below and let's get
started
so first up he tokyo or sakura is now
live for everyone on all platforms so if
you did not have the season pass you can
now purchase her for 15,000 steal and
now you can actually start enjoying the
character so definitely go do that as
soon as you can after you watch this
video on top of that there's also going
to be a new arcade quest called Sal Mesa
continues I believe that's a
continuation of one of the older arcade
quests we had called Sal Mesa I could
totally be wrong I haven't really played
many of the arcade quests recently on
top of that there's a new effect in the
shop called the theft of fire for 5000
steal on all heroes it's a pretty small
calming effect it kind of reminds me of
that vortac ER one that we got during
the event so I'm not really sure if this
is like a reskin or something but I
remember it being back in season 9 but I
totally could be wrong let me know what
you guys think if that's cool enough for
you to buy the 5000 steal with next up
is the state of balance and here's a
quick picture of the duel winnings among
all characters in season 9 which do
include black prior there's a hell of a
lot of stuff going on on this photo so
I'll try to you know kind of piece this
together but as you can see Tsubaki jaye
jaye and Ken say and black Pryor are
towards the top and Peacekeeper
Highlander conqueror and gladiator are
towards the bottom in terms of overall
pick rate with PK being the lowest of 38
percent and basically to give you an
idea of what this is on the left side as
a character and then at the top is
another set of characters and it shows
their comparison so for example I don't
remember the the terms and the actual
numbers specifically let's say a shougo
key goes up against the T on D and on
the Left issue go key and he has a 30
whereas T on D has 70 that means out of
out of like a hundred matches 30% of the
time jugo key will win 70 percent of the
time T on D will win meaning T on D is
super powerful against the shougo key
and shougo key is not as powerful
against e on d that's not actually any
of the numbers that's just a big example
for me to kind of explain what this is
what
on the very far right you can kind of
see the overall numbers which takes all
the numbers in their row adds them in an
average and then you can kind of see
what the little bit of a dual tier list
is and like I stated before you go he JJ
can say and black Pryor are gonna be at
the top with peacekeeper Highlander
conquer and glad at the bottom so which
kind of sucks me being a glad player him
being at the bottom but and I can also
understand black Pryor being at the top
this is a season 90 list so a lot of
people especially in the beginning were
probably not used to black Pryor so that
can obviously give him a little bit of
height because of his newer abilities
that he had and now this is going to be
the same exact setup that we saw before
except this is only going to be platinum
players and above the first one was just
every one of the community could have
been a really bad player or a really
good player but now this is just only
platinum players in a bug in terms of
ranked and as you can see JJ is now at
the top instead of second and no Bowie
went completely down at the bottom and
most of the Wulin are now climbing and
they're pretty higher now with new shoe
being in fourth this is mostly just
showing some of the higher level players
and playing a character compared to the
whole community
next up is Dominion and overall
basically means all the players in the
community the top four percent is
platinum and above and on the left is
the win rate and on the right is the
pick rate and of course that's split up
between overall win rate overall pick
rate top 4% win rate top 4% pick rate is
a little bit it's kind of easier to see
with this graph that they made but it
can be a little bit confusing I just
wanted to clear that up and to basically
summarize this jjr emotion and Kensei
earned the top three in platinum and
just everyone in general for the highest
Dominion win rate and I get all of them
except our Musha I don't know if I'm
missing something but I'm pretty sure
our Musha really isn't that great and
shout out to again peacekeeper ring
gladiator forming at the bottom again in
bolt centers for win rate you could find
your main and see how the data stacks up
here but I that's what I've just been
noticing for pick rate BP is absolutely
killing it at the top but this is a
little bit inflated because you of
course have to realize that this is
season 9 he's the new character so
people kind of want to play him a bit so
when they do this season state of
balance for C for this season of 10 of
season 10 I'm assuming soccer or hito
Curie is gonna be at the top next up is
breached
same as before JJ can say Inara Musa are
in the top three for the win rate except
anusha is actually at the very top in
one of the SEC's
which is kind of awkward seeing as she
has the highest win rate but also the
lowest pick rate with 1.8% either every
single new ship player that plays her is
an absolute god or something else is
going on with breach obviously this is a
game mode for assassin really a game
mode for assassin so this can be a
little bit troublesome for new ship
layers but I feel like it also might
have to do with her caltrop feat which
is making quick work of those pikemen
and getting out of battles and stuff
that could total that's just my opinion
I've never really played nutri I think
she's still level 1 for me so I'm not
really sure how new show plays in breach
that I might she might actually be
incredibly good she might be one of the
few exceptions that assassins are crazy
good for breach and then the same for JJ
he has the fourth lowest pick in the
overall community yet is the highest in
terms of win rate so that's just a few
things I noticed after looking to this
very briefly there's a lot of info being
thrown out at this at once
and I just kind of wanted to summarize
some of the key points about this the
reason they do this stuff is because
they have future plans by looking at the
data who can they buff who can they nerf
and stuff like that for future plans
though they definitely want to be
working on rolling away from moves
another term is just called escaping
although they have talked about this for
two straight seasons and nothing drastic
has really changed so I'm not really
sure what they're going out here as well
as making combat a lot more interesting
the problem is that some moves hit many
players often but not the tournament
players that kind of want to balance
this I mentioned that this should have
done at 50 millisecond intervals instead
of a hundred so right now we have 500
milliseconds 600 milliseconds
700 800 stuff like that most and even
400 of course if you have the generosity
of having a 400 millisecond light attack
which most characters do the problem is
that 500 is kind of debatable it's
pretty slow most players can actually
block a parry that with 400 being a
little bit too quick so I said I I had
an idea that they could raise this
interval to 50 so instead of having 400
and 500 we now have 450 which is a
pretty middle portion of that section
even 550 can work as well just to have a
small middle ground and this might make
a decent change then what this might
make no change at all but I just thought
the dead be something interesting
because I don't really know why we're
going over a hundred milliseconds when
we can easily be cutting that in half in
50 and getting more precise data
hey guys that's gonna be the end of the
beta hope you guys did enjoy it like I
said you can always go back and check
your stuff if you're a radar man and you
want to check that you're a shaman may
want to see how she goes against like
the entire community just to remember
that this is for season 9 and not season
10 so this Reiter stunning chat change
that everyone's raving about has
actually not taken into effect yet
because this is only for this season
that has happened season 9 was just your
standard Raider before the rework just
hit just to keep that in mind and also a
quick shout out to Clarissa or mistress
on the for honoured dev stream she ended
up talking about evidence tournament
which i commentated it is on my discord
in the community in the announcements
tab if you want to check that and I do
believe that it might still be up
somewhere on infinite stream or wherever
it happens to be it's like a four-hour
stream that means another content
creator tailing Dylan ended up Co
commentating and infinite was actually
hosting the tournament was a hell of a
lot of fun I saw a lot of you guys there
and we're definitely going to be getting
a lot more tournaments like with Xbox
and PC and as soon as those go live I
will try to update everybody so have the
notifications turn on so I'll try to
update everyone in the community tab so
people can get in and if you do want to
and stuff like that just make sure
you're stay tuned on his discord so that
you will know of all updates with the
recent tournaments that he will have
guys that's gonna be it like the video
if you do enjoy subscribe before a new I
covered the informational site a
foreigner that being balanced changes
hero updates pageants and leaks if you
want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner I never miss on an update if
we stay subscribe to the channel a
Twitter and discord or be in the
description down below and my two most
recent videos are going to be popping up
on screen during the outro and about two
seconds but with that take care guys
have a girl yesterday and peace out
[Music]